gotcha
i don't think anything's gonna
yeah
no okay so let me fill you in
about this time last year i made this
really high-powered nerf gun was so
powerful it could destroy glass
turned out pretty cool so after we did
the video we set it up on the shelf
worked as a display piece it's kind of
cool to me like walking in a place and
seeing something that like i put a lot
of effort into building and in this
particular instance
it led right to tragedy this didn't
happen on cameras no no cameras were
rolling it was a cold november night me
and carmichael were editing away and ren
nico were hack-sacked and things were
getting rowdy
wren in a desperate attempt he's just
committing to this foot goes right into
the shell hits full force
my gun tumbles down
hits the ground and shatters into a
thousand pieces maybe not a thousand
pieces more like a million pieces dude
those artist recreations are like
literally so realistic they're giving me
flashbacks to that day
just give me a moment
i collected the parts put them in the
workshop and i said i'm gonna fix you
gun and then the end of the year
happened and we got really busy and i
didn't have time it just so happens that
we have some down time right now but the
studio's been cleaned and i don't really
know
where all the parts are i'm embarking on
a glorious journey to reforge my gun but
i want to take it a step further build
something that i've been kind of like
thinking about for a while now i want to
build a net gun
more specifically i want to build a
barrel attachment which can be
interchangeable on the current gun body
so i put the parts here that's the last
i saw them
and i'm not seeing them now i hope they
didn't throw them away
there
[Music]
it's gone oh man
this freaking sweet muzzle break that
sam 3d printed
oh man
i hope i can even get the main body of
the gun reforged as it was
this is so sad dude those of you who
didn't see the original video fill it up
back here the air is stored in here goes
into this drill handle that we modified
when you click the trigger it opens this
sprinkler valve which releases the air
into the barrel and then shoots the dart
out now there's been a fracture here
what what you could do don't replace
this broken piece you get a pvc pipe
that's slightly smaller in circumference
and you put on the inside that can go
across both we're just going to prime
then we're going to cement a wonderful
time
this is like cemented shut i hate when
my cement cans get cemented i'm going to
try
yes the can technique
from the ashes of fire shall be woken
oh man this one's a good don't breathe
that
i renewed shall be blade that was broken
i'm about to cut this
the crownless again shall be king
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
get out of here
that's better
[Music]
come on go on shoot get out of here
so like what is this that you're making
i'm making the gun that i had until you
broke it
okay and then i'm going to make a net
gun have you ever been trapped by a net
uh
once back in 64.
[Music]
[Music]
all right
i have successfully reforged the rifle
let's get this off
now it's time to begin on the net gun
attachment for the barrel
d1 net mechanism really
i'm expecting these to fire out somewhat
fast
gotcha
yes
all i have to do is aim a little bit
higher especially i mean the net's going
to be wider than the string is too
well it's very important that when i
actually do the net assembly so that the
spread is even and they don't pull each
other down in the air
this net is really hard to work with
though because it's very thin and it
loves to tangle on stuff i suppose
that's the nature of a net though do you
guys need net
i could probably net the whole world
with this never empathize with fish as
much as i do now
we finally got the net cut down it was
huge cleaned up the borders of it and
now i'm attaching one of the darts to
each corner hopefully when they shoot
out they'll spread the net evenly
we're gonna try the dangle one
almost
okay let me try it ready
three two one
i know
oh what are you guys doing in there you
gotta use a 22 ram set to put the bottom
plates in that uses a 22 charge three
two one
freaking dowels keep going through the
net and causing these crazy tangles
this ain't making no pot pie from marie
calendar that's for sure
yeah man i think we need a
we're gonna need to order a bigger net
a better net a bigger and better net
this net is huge as i expected so i need
to cut it down to size nick it means i'm
so glad you got this net because today's
episode is sponsored by expressvpn oh
we're doing that we're doing that we're
doing that right now and you know how
this net is like captures all this stuff
and it's all around us it's kind of like
the internet that's right and you're out
there and you're inside of the internet
like i am right now inside of this net
sending out my data all over the world
i'm on amazon i'm on facebook i'm on
youtube i'm sending out all my data well
guess what without the encryption
abilities of a vpn your information is
just out there for for anyone who wants
it to just snatch it up just like if you
wanted to snatch up my data that's all
you have to do with expressvpn for just
seven dollars a month you can encrypt
your data before it even hits the
internet you can use expressvpn on your
phone or you can use it on your pc as an
extension even put it on mom and dad's
pc no problem protect them too so just
check this out say that say that i have
my data here and that's your data and
i'm out there and i want to grab it
right yeah without a vpn all i have to
do is this
and it's mine
with a vpn
i just
try to get it and i can't because it's
encrypted and so all you guys gotta do
is go to expressvpn.com corridor crew
it's got a 30-day money-back guarantee
also if you buy the year package you get
three months free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n dot com
c r c-o-r-r-i-d-o-r-c-r-e-d w take back
your internet privacy today
what what was i doing
what was i just doing
i think we all learned something
valuable about vpns today
but uh now i gotta take this net out to
the main floor and i gotta cut it down
to size round two here
[Music]
walking around aimlessly
not a care in the world i don't think
anything's gonna
gotcha both oh no
it's way too heavy well i mean i've
spent like three days in total working
on this if you combine all the hours the
darts are going with my with my nerf gun
like it has enough power to get those
darts out there at a nice speed but it's
the net that's holding them back if i
can just reduce the weight of the net by
a half i think that should do it i just
said half because i didn't do the math
but it's going to be a significant
amount this net is looking great and
it's a lot lighter and i can already
tell
it's going to tangle a lot less and be
easier
to untangle if it does tangle
i can i can feel just by scooping all
this up that's a considerable amount of
weight that i just shed from the net
all right and now i'm about to test
if this actually was effective
[Music]
how old are you guys
jesus christ you guys can't be that
young
um i've heard of john wayne
[Music]
follow me
effective range isn't that great but
in a quick pinch i think this is perfect
for netting someone around the corner
got him
[Music]
you have no idea how satisfying that is
after a freaking three days
of trying to make this thing work
[Music]
hello my name's nick steele for the last
11 minutes i've been building a net gun
today i'm here at one of youtube's
hottest streets
i'm going to catch myself some
influencers for my zoo
[Music]
i'm going to talk to you about some
writing opportunities for the next
science videos so i got a few good ideas
oh god got him oh my god
you got it working that works great
there was a bunch of clutter all over
the desk
and like
someone said it wasn't even labeled
someone put the thing
[Music]
oh got him come on we're going to the
zoo oh my god
him
so i was going to enjoy my lunch
[Music]
there's a christian nearby and i'm gonna
catch him
that time it was too powerful this is
the bolt 500 with the tarot deck
transmitter built into it
i'm running it on the camera it's
daylight bright and it automatically
connects to my little director monitor
like
it was this big
but they were thinking no the monitor
was this big
metal rig and two big i figured it out
close ranges yes it's pretty effective
if the air doesn't all leak out thanks
like i kind of want to make a new air
tank that actually like doesn't leak
um but for now i think it's time to
restore the gun to its original resting
place
[Music]
[Music]
subscribe
[Music]
tarnation
merlin's pants caesar's ghosts fiddle
sticks love that one snickerdoodles jeez
tur willagers mother smucker